[Music]
all right well i have a story here
of this home in south carolina what's up
homes
mm-hmm this homes so there were these
four
adults that were riding their
four-wheelers
just having a grand old time that's some
south carolina
yeah and they just decided to check out
the local abandoned house
and they were like hey i heard this
house is haunted let's go check it out
still on track white people not racially
based but
i don't know but usually in the horror
movie white people investigate it
that's what the whites do yep what's
going on this is what the house looks
like
oh that looks pretty [ __ ] up yeah
why is it glowing on the bottom it's
lights yeah
here's another angle of it it's kind of
hard to see but this is the house it's
glowing again
and and one of the one of the adults in
the group an 18 year old
huge adult i mean he has an adult huh 18
that's an adult
it's just funny what are the adults
because everyone else was teased
no i said four adults one of the adults
okay
so he he went to the back and he saw a
freezer
and i'm i think this is the freezer i
can't tell i don't know is there a body
in there
and he found a decomposed body human
body human body
so they did good so that was a haunted
house
no just someone dumped a body that is
and so the police went and in a
refrigerator they got the
freezer like a freezer was it plugged in
that's a good way to
do the lay down freeze it's gonna stink
then that's industrial too
like um
they end up smelling something and then
they went to investigate they actually
checked out
the body hell no that sounds like the
stupidest thing to do like
oh like we heard a scary noise inside
let's go check it out you know like and
i mean people get the stereotype is true
then huh why people like to investigate
scary [ __ ] you know what it is
i don't know where you wouldn't though i
think i would
i think they're genetically wired to
pull out a flashlight
and investigate in the middle of the
night when they hear something
i have a neighbor who started yelling
randomly at night and i
and every time it happens i go outside
and try to check out what the [ __ ] is
going on and i get super pissed and
nikki's always like what the [ __ ] are
you doing checking it out just stay
inside but i can't i can't it's because
of my whiteness
yeah because you know what i do
is i'll i don't even have a purse but
i'll go out and buy one and i'll clench
it tight when i hear something later
or yeah well that's only if you hear
something offensive oh my god i think
it's a rich
asian lady pearls i think uh um yeah a
normal asian lady would just clench her
purse tight
and then we have a backpack that's close
enough it's not a purse
it is it's you don't clench your
backpack it's a murse
anyway so they found this body and it
was
it was decomposing so badly
that the cops don't even know this is a
male or female holy [ __ ] so it's just a
flesh blob they'll have to test the
bones and channels well they said that
the body was still partially dressed in
jeans and socks
oh that's a that's a push for equality
and gender
yeah why do the cops care about what if
it's male or female to find out who this
is oh okay
i was just having his back yeah but they
shouldn't judge yeah they really
shouldn't
i don't think so well anyway so then the
sheriff's office went over
to investigate the death and then two
days
after the discovery of this body guess
what happened
someone farted yeah someone did fart
super hard probably i mean someone in
this planet
holy [ __ ] was like no at the police
station oh no my husband went missing
no what happened someone guessed someone
showed up to the house
no someone admitted to the murder the
body disappeared
no because the cops have them how big
does a fart have to be to be a
newsworthy fart another body was in the
the three second slot no
but uh go back to the someone going to
the house okay well just say it for me
then go over and go in that room
oh they they found out that someone
revisited the house because we're going
to come back and get the body and get
rid of it
um kind of close where you're moving oh
they checked the basement
and it's like that movie from japan
where like the the the parasite
parasite or oh that's korea korea you're
getting your asians mixed up
oh it's a whiteness we'll cut it we'll
cut it we'll cut it we're fine
no okay fine i'll tell you there's a
blender and there's no more body parts
in there no no but in the basement
that's where they found the most [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
they found the whole family there oh
yeah no just one guy one guy i think do
you even watch someone
parasite what are you talking about i
found one guy isn't that a spoiler alert
no what do you mean
it was one guy did you watch the whole
movie no there's one guy his wife
his wife lived up there yeah that's why
she had to go to spoiler alert i'm
talking about that spoiler alert
but they didn't find the whole body and
the family no no we're not talking about
people
we're not talking about parasites anyway
what happened here is two days later
the house got burned down oh [ __ ] damn
so they went to go destroy the evidence
is what happened it's what it seems like
i was the closest one you didn't give me
any points no i said
they went back and they tried to get rid
of the body yeah and then i was like oh
yeah but that's like our body was gone
we we killed this person
years ago we're gonna wait until this
exact date somehow
two days before that maybe weeks the
body was gone
the body already got taken we're just
talking about in terms of
the decomposition because the
composition not a good guess is what i'm
saying that's not weak so that's closer
than farting
no no you don't know if someone
was farting and his friend [ __ ] lit
their butt on fire and it [ __ ] burned
the highway
out to the store he got his legs up like
this his friends got a match
i was gonna add to my story too they
came and they checked the house
and then they came back and they burned
it i said the exact same thing same
thing
do you think that they burned it with a
friend's fart nope
okay we could have combined forces and
burn it down
anyway so this is what the house looks
like now
it's burned down only the fire that's a
strong chimp
it's still glowing that's not weird that
should be uh
a chimney or a fireplace commercial well
shouldn't all fireplaces survive a
[ __ ] fire
south carolina chimneys i feel like
chimneys should survive fire still
it has to come to all chimneys i don't
see the house but
every single one would that be a good
way to uh
basically not act like you're the person
that killed them
is by calling the cops to be like we
just found his body oh
and it is it is but police thought from
a police officer's point of view
the person that reports it is just the
uh automatic suspect already
usually it's the people who are the
closest but the cops not thinking about
this logically because why would i
report it if i did
it yeah
so you want to scratch me off the list
there buddy
back pocket for his wallet you might be
able to do that you might find something
promising there a little something for
yourself
it's like ten dollars it's keep it you
keep it it's yours
you work hard he's like when they go to
jail they're like you took the bribe you
[ __ ]
it was like bro it's ten dollars that's
funny but yeah so
they're saying obviously the cops find
that
suspicious the fact that the [ __ ]
house just burnt to a crisp
and how did they know what do you mean
well the hustle isn't there it was burnt
down
no no no no how did the people know to
burn it down because the cops came and
took the body yeah
it's probably big news in that town like
who knows i don't know does nothing
happen where is it it's like
uh in south korea norway south carolina
why is it with the south wood naming
other places
like birmingham too yeah well maybe
because
europeans came to america that's right
forgot about those bikes
but yeah so anyway so then the for the
previous tenant
who had that house said that his
daughter grew up
out there and it has really affected her
to know that somebody would come out
there
and do such a thing as dispose the body
in the old freezer on the back porch is
just a terrible thing
and then when he was asked like well is
it true that it's haunted
and then the guy was like well i mean
i might have killed a few the house has
its own energy kind of thing
so he did say that he did confirm that
it's haunted then pretty much because he
said that
the there was a rocking chair in the
house and sometimes it was just rock by
itself
i hate rock pictures i don't like
rocking so the house burned itself down
would you be more scared of a rocking
chair inside the house or a regular
chair just walking back and forth
well if it's windy
it's all totally still a rocking chair
for me rocking chair yeah and then also
that there were some voices in the house
and it's been like that for years yeah
because they were killing people i don't
know
it sounds like a ghost joe oh yeah and
then also they've determined that the
cause
of the fire is undetermined at this
point
this is like two movies stuck together
it's like a murder mystery and a horror
film
yeah with a little bit of parasite a
little bit of nah
please okay is there a basement i don't
know you know what sucks is like
whenever i think of the countryside i
think it's so safe and nice and then now
i think it's like
meth and dangerous dude you ever drive
through it though at night
like with your high beams on or whatever
like there is no light nothing
[ __ ] sakes like it's scary as hell and
that makes me feel good
i wish to be more in the like in the
country but like if we built a downtown
in like yosemite but why there's going
to be [ __ ] homeless people there
yeah oh what a yuma just i'm just
arizona
yeah but like i need if i live there
honestly i would need like a thousand
rings
rings yeah i get doorbells like on every
corner
oh yeah yeah yeah the second like even
like a fly flies
all the lights pop up in the alert
that's a lot of doorbells
then why be in nature i think the cool
[ __ ] about nature is there's no one
there and then you get someone that with
the axe murderer coming
that's why you carry a gun but there are
ghosts rocking chairs that's why you
hold a jesus cross and a buddha [ __ ]
jade necklace
and you have a buddha bracelet and you
have some sage in your back pocket
and you have a little bible and you have
silver bullets
in your gun for werewolves or criminals
why is the day you're taking a shower
and then you also need to go to an mri
so you took off all your jewelry
i would save my silver bullets if they
were criminals
for the werewolves personally oh
smart move well i just have it loaded
for either war i see true because i mean
i'm very efficient wait you guys didn't
see parasite because at the end of the
movie
the whole family's in the house no they
have to hide downstairs
and they're they're hiding under the
table what table there's always that's
not the end of the movie that's not the
end
of it towards the end it's a goddamn
goddamn long beginning i'll tell you
that
drinking this movie i was like two of
them i was really drunk watching this
movie and i remember it
better than you they were drunk in that
part too look
they're all under the table the whole
family under the table and they watch
the other person yeah
they watch the the dad and mom [ __ ]
while watching the kid outside yeah
and then they go party in singapore it's
a big part of singapore
huge party in singapore and then they i
do remember that
and they were so rich so that's right
so crazy too there was like a crazy rich
asians movie
yeah i haven't seen that but not that
many had a massive party at the end
crazy rich person i saw it yeah
beautiful wedding personally was just a
rip-off of crazy birch asians
i know right but with scariness you know
what they should have called parasite
crazy rich freeloaders oh that's good
[ __ ] well they were reloading off of
the rich people yeah
yeah well the free though the rich
people were freelance
off the poor people yeah
[Music]
you